und jetzt das heute schon mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in ein es ist heiß
auch jetzt noch um viertel vor elf bis
zu
37,1 grad gab es heute in deutschland
42,9 in frankreich die früheste
hitzewelle seit fast einem
dreivierteljahr 100 dort in spanien
haben waldbrände bereits tausende hektar
wald vernichtet norditalien leidet unter
der schlimmsten dürre seit 70 jahren in
großbritannien messen die behörden den
dritten tag in folge neue hitzerekorde
für diese jahreszeit und kalendarisch
hat der sommer noch nicht einmal
begonnen katrina
waldbrand in frohnsdorf südlich von
berlin löschen geht nur aus der distanz
im boden laut munition aus zwei
weltkriegen 80 hektar wald stehen in
flammen bereits rund 220 waldbrände in
diesem jahr zählt brandenburg heute
mussten sie landesweit die höchste
waldbrandstufe ausrufen
diese temperaturen mit dem wind und den
vielen nadelholz beständen die machen
letztendlich diese region hier im osten
von deutschland
doch so zu einer brandgefährdeten region
die teilweise auch vergleichbar ist mit
diesen situationen die wir in den
mittelmeerländern haben die spree bei
cottbus wichtig für die wasserversorgung
von berlin schon jetzt braucht der fluss
zusätzliches wasser aus talsperren und
die stadt cottbus hat die entnahme von
wasser aus flüssen und seen tagsüber zum
beispiel für den kleingarten untersagt
im letzten jahr war es dann glaube ich
schon ende juli erst als das passierte
aber nun hatten wir ja am anfang schon
gleich beizeiten einen sehr trockenen
frühling und wir haben insgesamt in der
region grundwasserstände die sind bis zu
80 zentimeter und dann unter dem
früheren grundwasserständen nicht nur
für die umwelt auch für den menschlichen
körper ist wasser gerade in diesen tagen
wichtig klinikum stuttgart hitze
patienten mussten an diesem tag versorgt
werden viele holten sich auch ratschläge
am telefon
es kommt doch vermehrt dazu dass
patienten gerade ältere patienten oder
patienten aus pflegeeinrichtungen
hierher gebracht werden weil
festgestellt wird den geht es nicht gut
die konnten nicht genügend trinken oder
haben nicht genügend getrunken und dann
müssen sie ja eingeliefert werden um
intravenös flüssigkeit zugeführt zu
bekommen in einem breiten streifen von
südwestdeutschland bis nach ostsachsen
wurden temperaturen um die 35 grad
gemessen pflanzen leiden unter der
trockenheit und hitze hier ein feld bei
leipzig
ein stück weit ist der trend den man
jetzt über die letzten jahrzehnte
beobachtet durchaus
stärker als es uns auch klimamodelle für
den gleichen zeitraum projizieren und
das bedeutet dass die reale welt
durchaus extremer ist wer in diesen
tagen draußen unterwegs ist spielt schon
jetzt deutlich die härte des
klimawandels
er kann jetzt das machen was wir immer
machen wollte so skizziert eine aus dem
unterlegenen lager bei der afd die
zukunft mit dem alten und neuen
parteichef timo kubala er hat auf dem
parteitag zwar das schlechteste ergebnis
bei so einer wahl in der afg geschichte
eingefahren aber mit der neuen co
vorsitzenden alois seidl an seiner seite
und mit einer reihe von wunschkandidaten
als stellvertreter hat er die als
gemäßigter geltenden in der partei
geschlagen offen bleibt wie genau die
afg sich jetzt inhaltlich ausrichten
wird nach einer ganzen serie von
wahlschlappen david geppert
es ist gute miene zu einem miesen
ergebnis tino keller ist wieder afg chef
mit dem schlechtesten ergebnis eines afd
vorsitzenden in der afg geschichte nur
knapp über 50% und nicht alleine wie er
lange wollte sondern mit alice weidl
neben ihm in der doppelspitze die auch
noch deutlich besser abschneidet der
neue alte chef redet sich das ergebnis
irgendwie schön
es ist der aufbruch der afd ist uns
gelungen in den neuen bundesvorstand
alle strömungen zu vereinen damit wir
gestärkt aus diesem bundesparteitag
herausgehen in einen strom hineingehen
der uns stärkt es ist weniger ein strom
der ihn stärkt als eine strömung die ihn
duldet der anführer der radikalen büren
höke tritt zwar nicht selber an aber
drückt reihenweise seine leute durch
diese neue bundesvorstand entspricht
bisher vollständig meinem geschmack es
ist der geschmack eines
rechtsextremisten einen vorstand von rcs
gladen der durchmarsch der radikalen
wird zum desaster der für ard
verhältnisse gemäßigt darin wer in
seiner bewerbungsrede sowas hier fordert
verliert
wir müssen aus dem tief indem wir sind
dringend raus kommen mit einer neuen
politischen kommunikation mit einem
neuen stil mit einem neuen wind dass die
wähler da draußen auch sehen ahadi afd
da tut sich was positives wir brauchen
auch eine charme offensive richtung
wähler weniger verbessert hat weniger
gehässigkeit doch gehässigkeit ist
gerade gefragt auf diesem parteitag das
hat alles weil verstanden die in ihrer
rede gegen den ex-chef genüsslich
nachtritt und damit punktet
vor einer woche in einer groß
angekündigten pressekonferenz seinen
beitritt zur katholischen mini partei
zentrum erklärt
er hat dafür extra einen kostspieligen
saal in der bundespressekonferenz in
berlin gebucht und tatsächlich hätte für
dieses trauerspiel ein beichtstuhl in
einer friedhofskapelle
aufgereiht die er am alten wird heute
lückenlos ausradiert es ist der tag der
abrechnung die radikalen hatten rache
geschworen als morten 1 den rechtsextrem
andreas kalbitz aus der partei warf
keiner von denen die damals mit gestimmt
haben ist mehr dabei abgewählt oder
hingeschmissen nach einer wütenden
häutung ein lager endgültig im abseits
es tatsächlich so dass die ankündigung
von tino copala
dass man alle strömungen im
bundesvorstand abbilden wollen die ich
erfreut zur kenntnis genommen hatte in
keiner weise umgesetzt ist war ein
verloren mitglieder verloren personell
und inhaltlich ausgedünnt die afg in der
krise sucht den neuanfang sucht ihr heil
im radikal
der alte und neue fdp-chef heißt also
kino kubala kunden am tag
übernahm sie was es ist sehr heiß heute
jetzt mal abgesehen vom wetter wie sehr
mussten sie schwitzen um parteichef
bleiben zu können
nun ich bin mit 53,0 noch etwas als
parteivorsitzender bestätigt worden das
ist immer schwierig eine bestätigung
auch in der ard zu bekommen ich freue
mich sehr über das ergebnis aber auch
mit demut zur kenntnis und wenn man
schaut dass friedrich merz dreimal
antreten musste und parteivorsitzender
zu werden sieht man dass es eine afd
also wesentlich konsolidiert dazu geht
jetzt ist allerdings chef einer partei
der zdf- politbarometer ganz vorne liegt
mit den 26 prozent während die afd zehn
niederlagen in folge hat der herr grupp
aller sie wollten als jemand der bisher
schon dran war jetzt erneuerung schaffen
wie viel rückenwind gibt denn ein
wahlergebnis von 53 prozent
wissen wir haben heute den gesamten
bundesvorstand gewählt mit mehreren
personen die die partei repräsentieren
und das war meine aufgabe und das war
auch mein wille dass wir hier alle
strömungen alle legitimen ströme unserer
partei verein ist uns gelungen und mit
dem heutigen tage ist die erneuten
beendet und sind auch die
personaldiskussion beendet wir werden
uns jetzt auf die programmatischen
punkte unserer partei konzentrieren wir
werden uns jetzt um die sorgen und nöte
deutschlands und der vielen bürger hier
interessieren und für diese leute auch
in ein politikangebot stellen dass die
alternative wieder steigt und das
natürlich auch wieder die alternative
für deutschland starke wahlergebnisse
erzielt vereinigen sie tatsächlich alle
strömungen wenn herr höcker jetzt sagte
der neue vorstand des einer voll nach
meinem geschmack
wissen sie es gibt insgesamt heute
ergebnisse die über 70 75 prozent sind
es ist auch ein vorstand nach meinem
geschmack und auch der vielen
delegierten die haben hier heute
entschieden die haben hier heute gewählt
wie gesagt wir haben alle strömungen
vereint wir sind jetzt ein starker strom
ich denke wir werden wie gesagt die
lagerkämpfe die im letzten
bundesvorstand erneuten verursacht
wurden in der vergangenheit belassen und
werden können uns jetzt auf die zukunft
konzentrieren wir müssen uns jetzt um
die aufgaben in deutschland kümmern wir
werden uns jetzt um die interessen
deutschlands kümmern in und im ausland
wir brauchen keine werte geleitete
außenpolitik sondern eine
interessengeleitete der politik zum
wohle der deutschen damit unsere energie
preise wieder sinken das mit bezahlbarem
wohnraum haben und dass auch unsere
renten finanzierbar sind das sind die
aufgaben der zukunft dass wir wieder für
unsere bürger politik in deutschland
machen frau weiter sagt schon mal lasst
mich mal machen an sie gerichtet wenn
die frage aber eigentlich an sie ging
jetzt hat sie heute auch ein besseres
ergebnis als sie ist alice weidl jetzt
so die die heimliche ware parteichefin
der afd
wissen sie wir arbeiten mit alice weiter
beide vertrauensvolle und
partnerschaftliche auch schon im
fraktionsvorstand zusammen wir waren das
spitzenkandidaten team der
bundestagswahl wurden dort mit 72
prozent gewählt wir unterstützen uns
gegenseitig und jeder hat man seine
schwächephase und jeder hat man eine
starke phase das wird auch in zukunft
sicherlich zu sein also von daher ist
das bei partnerschaften so auch in der
politik und wir fühlen uns getragen von
dem votum des parteitages und wir werden
auch weiterhin gemeinsam erfolgreich
politik gestalten und das ist jetzt die
aufgabe wie gesagt morgen kümmern wir
uns um die programmatik um inhalte ich
denke das wollen die wähler das wollen
die bürger wissen und nicht permanent
und mehr personalien diskutiert haben
wollen sagt tino copala der alte und
neue hp-chef vielen dank
sehr gerne
und das interview haben wir aus
termingründen um 21 uhr aufgezeichnet so
anna du beginnst jetzt den
nachrichtenüberblick mit der lage in der
ukraine christian der ukrainische
präsident jens g hat zum ersten mal seit
beginn des russischen angriffskriegs die
frontlinie im süden des landes besucht
in der stadt nikolajew machte er sich
ein bild von der zerstörung
anschluss verteilte er orden unter
anderem an den dortigen
militärgouverneur und den bürgermeister
erst gestern hatte es in der stadt einen
raketenangriff in einem wohngebiet
gegeben zwei menschen starben 20 wurden
verletzt
bundespräsident steinmeier hat die
weltkunstausstellung documenta in kassel
eröffnet und ging dabei auch auf die
antisemitismus debatte rund um die
kritik an israelischer politik sei
erlaubt sagte steinmeier doch wo kritik
an israel umschlage in die
infragestellung seiner existenz da sei
die grenze überschritten dem
indonesischen kuratorin kollektiv war
vorgeworfen worden bei der ausstellung
künstler eingebunden zu haben die einen
boykott israels unterstützen oder
antisemit antisemitisch sein
fast elf jahre nach dem massaker auf der
norwegischen insel utoya ist eine
nationale gedenkstätte für die opfer
eingeweiht worden am fähranleger der die
insel mit dem festland verbindet steht
nun ein mahnmal mit 77 bronze sollen
eine für jedes todesopfer an der
zeremonie mit überlebenden und
hinterbliebenen nahmen auch kronprinz
haakon teil
2011 hatte der rechtsextremist breivik
im osloer regierungsviertel 8 menschen
mit einer bombe getötet und anschließend
auf der insel utoya 69 vor allem junge
teilnehmer eines politischen sommercamps
erschossen
die schwimm wm in budapest hat begonnen
und das mit einer ersten medaille für
das deutsche team lukas mertens hat im
finale über 400 meter freistil silber
gewonnen schneller war nur der
australier winning team und zwar 1,63
sekunden bronze gewann der brasilianer
costa
in der handball champions league ging es
am abend für den thw kiel um den einzug
ins finale
der deutsche rekordmeister traf in köln
auf titelverteidiger barcelona und zu
sehen gab es eine kämpferische
vorstellung
bei kiel in weiß läuft das spiel über
den kreis in der torreichen ersten
hälfte besonders gut patrick wiencek
setzt sich ein ums andere mal gegen
wassers der kunden durch aber auch
fehler sind dabei die spanier spielen
schnell zur pause liegt der thw mit 18
zu 19 zurück beim final four turnier in
köln zuvor hat sich dazu neu robert
andreas wolf mit den polnischen meister
aus kiel ins finale am sonntag gespielt
die klima schaffen das nicht beim
titelverteidiger aus barcelona tut sich
alle gourmets hervor die katalanen
setzten sich am ende klar durch mit 30
zu 34 geht das halbfinale für kiel
verloren für die norddeutschen bleibt es
bei vier champions league titel
zu den lottozahlen an diesem samstag die
lauten 18 23 26 37 45 46 superzahl 2
alle angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
und dies nach den hohen temperaturen
heute mit dem wetter weiter geht die
aussichten im norden regnet es morgen
sonst scheint lange die sonne später
kann es gewitter geben im süden und
südosten wird es bis zu 39 grad heiss im
nordwesten werden 20 bis 31 grad
erreicht auf den inseln 16 montag und
mittwoch werden eher unbeständig der
dienstag meist freundlich die große
hitze geht zu ende es bleibt aber warm
am mittwoch mit 19 bis 30 grad
und mit diesen aussichten entlassen wir
sie in eine heiße sommernacht bis morgen
hier gibt es die nächsten nachrichten
gegen viertel vor zwölf heute express
mit moritz neues
[Musik]